va-t-on vers un conflit entre la
sécurité sociale et les médecins la
question est posée depuis que la caisse
primaire centrale d'assurance maladie de
la région parisienne a annoncé la
décision prise par les trois caisses
maladie en question de déconventionner
un certain nombre de médecins
il est reproché à ses médecins d'avoir
établi des actes médicaux sans appliquer
dans plus de 50 % des cas le tarif
conventionnel un tarif qui permet vous
le savez le remboursement par la
sécurité sociale dans des conditions que
chacun connaît mais voyons cela
maintenant d'un peu plus près
plus de 150 médecins menacé d'être
dégagée de la convention nationale par
la caisse primaire centrale
on leur reproche d'avoir fait payer
systématiquement à leurs clients des
prix de visite ou de consultation
supérieur au tarif conventionnel fixé
actuellement à 23 francs seuls ont droit
à des dépassements d'honoraires les
médecins qui ont une autorité accrue par
leurs titres universitaires leurs
activités hospitalières ou leurs travaux
de recherche
si un médecin est dégagé de la
convention cela signifie pour lui la
perte d' avantages sociaux un régime
fiscal modifié il ne pourrait exercer
que dans des quartiers aisés
conséquences pour le malade les frais de
visite ou de consultation ne seront plus
remboursés que sur un tarif autoritaire
de 4 francs au lieu des 75 % du montant
de la visite les frais de pharmaciens ou
de laboratoire et en a remboursé
normalement en province des caisses ont
pris les mêmes décisions que celle de
paris des lettres de mises en garde ont
été adressées à plusieurs médecins
certains d'entre eux se sont engagés à
respecter désormais les tarifs de la
convention réaction des syndicats
médicaux français
certaines de ces décisions sont
irrégulières les dossiers doivent être
transmis à la commission médico sociale
paritaire
de son côté la caisse nationale dispose
d'un mois pour entériner ou non la
décision de la caisse primaire
c'est tout le problème de la convention
passée entre la sécurité sociale et les
médecins qui se trouve maintenant en
cause